hello welcome back to material from my
strategy guide on YouTube today is
episode 4 synergies part two and today
we're going to talk about what I think
is the strongest type of synergy in the
game and that is card draw Plus Card
discount I think after the first video I
made a lot of people got the impression
that I don't care about Mega credit
production and stuff like this and
that's probably my fault but no no no no
no this is where it's at this is really
really good if you have just a little
bit of money income but then on the
other hand you have a lot of cardboard
you have a lot of Card discount this is
how you can go about it's way stronger
than getting big acrylic production in
episode 16.1 which is a game I played on
the mashup I call it the power of card
draw this is like a perfect example of
what you could do with card draw Plus
Card discount I don't have a lot of
money to count that game but I still win
government so in this video I'm gonna do
my best to explain to you why I think
this type of synergy is so good can't
draw Plus Card discount then we're also
going to look at a theory crafting we
talked about a little bit in the last
video but today we're gonna like go all
in and talk about this deck because this
deck is like God mode made into a
styling head it got so much Capital so
much Card discount and a little bit of
money income and very very strong so in
the first video I gave this little bit
of a weird statement that I think the
value of discount cards is squared
meaning that if you have two this kind
of cards like Earth caterpillars like
with four Mega credit production if you
have three discount on all characters
like with nine Mega credit production as
you have four discount of cases with 16
Mega credit production obviously this is
not strictly true there's no like math
to back this up but it's just like the
mindset of the more discount cards you
can actually stack the better so for
instance if you have Earth catapult and
anti-gravity technology then you have a
discount of four on all the cards so
this is like kind of sort of like 16
Mega credit production but it's kind of
impossible to evaluate because it
depends on so many things right it
depends strictly on how many cars you
play per generation for example if you
play exactly four cards and Generation
Well then it is exactly like 16 Mega
credit production right but I would
argue that if you're having a good game
so in the mid to late game especially
this is gonna be way better than 16 Mega
pretty production so this is also where
the card draw element really comes in
because you need card draw to get the
best effect of these discounts and it
makes sense right because cars are just
so efficient if they're far cheaper so
you just need as many cars as humanly
possible so why am I saying that
discount on cards actually Stacks kind
of sort of exponentially because the
math I just laid out here doesn't really
support that the thing is if you're
getting this much discount maybe more
than likely you also have even more
discount on Space tags for example a lot
of cards like you would never consider
to play these cards but if you have so
much discount all of a sudden these
cards are available plays to you so the
point I'm trying to make here is that if
you have a lot of discount then all of a
sudden these kind of bad cars that you
wouldn't normally buy out of the four
cards in the research phase perhaps you
would normally maybe sell or something
all of a sudden these cards become good
especially if we're talking about space
tags because there's so many cards in
this game that actually make space text
cheaper like later in this video we're
gonna look at a game where I literally
have 17 discount on SpaceX and like I
mentioned in the mid to late game I
would argue that it is catapult and
anti-gravity technology is worth a lot
more than 60 Mega credit production just
because in the mid to late game if you
have a lot of card draw you will be
playing a lot more than four cards in
the last period generations and like I
mentioned before discount cards this is
the special juice you need when you're
going god mode
so the game on the mass ever talked
about before this is the starting hand I
had and as you can see I have a lot of
card draw I have a lot of makeup credit
it's kind of a good hand but it's not
God mode because what I'm using I'm
missing Card discount I have a little
bit of a terractor I have mass converter
but it's not enough I'm really missing
that special juice which is cut discount
but I'm getting it pretty early in this
game so this is why this game ends up
being so good so real quick like I
mentioned in the last episode this is
the best starting hand in existence I
believe this best starting hack you can
have ever however this is like some user
made cap so we're not going to talk
about today we are going to talk about
this hat and to be fair this is like
entirely Theory craft I didn't actually
have the starting hand this is only me
Theory crafting what is the best
possible hand you can have so why is
this hand not as good as the other one
where you use usermate card typically
because there's a little bit more card
draw in the other hand and also they
have death right and death Riders like
whiter but even better but this hand is
of course still absolutely broken I'm
gonna show you why so there are actually
three reasons why I decided to make this
part two the first reason is that out of
an entire chapter about Synergy I kind
of didn't feel like I talked enough
about the best Synergy in the game in my
opinion which is this card draw Plus
Card discount the second reason is that
while we talked a little bit about this
hand in this previous video I didn't
really explain to you why they send the
service and the third reason is I
actually tried this in a Solo game and I
was like oh it is completely broken so
I'm going to show you guys because it's
actually a lot of fun so even though
this is Theory craft and you can argue
well it has very little to do with real
terraforming masks because obviously you
cannot use your starting hand there's
still a lot of the same Concepts that
you can apply in your own game of
terraforming masks if you will this is
just like an enhanced example where it
goes completely god mode just so I can
show you what this can actually do when
you get this energy online the only
weakness of this deck is that the first
couple of generations are kind of slow
you can't really do much but that
doesn't really matter because by
Generation 4 you're still gonna go God
mode by the way you can address this
issue of having a slow start is just to
remove AI Central and corporate archives
and then you can substitute these with
supply drops and advanced allies and
actually I think this is going to to be
a little bit better because you're going
to have a way better generation one and
two and then you can you can start the
snowball a lot sooner and you could go
God mode maybe in generation three
instead of generation four but then you
are of course losing AI Central and I
think air Central Drew me like eight
cards in the game that I'm about to show
you so it's not like the end of the
world but you're also losing one science
tag so that Science Tech is pretty
important so you can play anti-gravity
technology but to be honest this is not
a problem at all because all of this
stuff that you're playing before you're
playing anti-gravity technology just by
playing this stuff you will draw like 30
cards so one of these cards is gonna be
a science tag it's not a problem but
that being said today we are gonna stick
with AI Central plus corporate archives
because a little bit prettier that your
starting hand has everything you need to
play anti-gravity technology all right
but let's break down the starting hand
why is this so completely overpowered
first of all I said this before but I
think these are the three best cardboard
cards you can have Master University
Olympus conference and spin-off
Department we have all of the three
cards in this opening hand so the arrows
here like pinpointing to all of the
stuff that gives card draw so as you can
see it's quite a lot so we also got
corporate archives and as Central and
then we've got high seek lab and this
card is also really good especially if
you have Quantum extract and mass
converter so you've got 10 energy
production so every generation it's
going to be a little less than this
because you also want to trade stuff
like this but you can tutor like seven
cards and just take one of these cards
it's really good kind of the same effect
as corporate archive so if you look at
it that way it's like really good and
then we also got Prime Luna which is
also perfect obviously because you're
drawing a card every time you play an
earth tag so just to give you a frame of
reference and the game I'm about to show
you it's gonna be only seven generations
but in those seven generations Park Leon
is gonna draw me 30 cards spin-off
department where you get a card every
time you play a card with 20 plus cost
that's also gonna draw me 30 cards I
believe Mars University is also going to
allow me to rotate 30 cards so it's
completely insane just compare that to
AI Central which is a lot more expensive
than Mars University yeah Central only
gives me like eight cards this is why if
you are gonna cut anything from the
stick I believe it should be here
central which kind of sounds crazy I
know and also an important thing to
realize about all this card draw is that
they're kind of boosting each other what
I mean is like if you're playing so many
cars naturally you're gonna see more
science text you're gonna see more Earth
text so the more card draw you have the
better Point lunar is the better Mars
University is the better Olympus
conferences so if you're able to stack
Capital like I'm doing here this is
going to make all the capital cars like
exponentially better especially the card
broadcast which has an effect like Point
Luna spin-off Department Olympus
conference Marsh University all of these
are drawing you a car based off of
something so if you're going guard mode
if you're having a really good game this
is like way more impactful than actually
AI Central because as intro is an action
you can only do that once per generation
so these arrows here are looking at the
card discount the library talked about
Earth catapult and air gravity
technology just this by itself is insane
then we also got Quantum extractor Mass
converter and Valley Trust already now
we have a discount on Space Tech and the
effect of really trust where you get two
discount on science tax is not like the
biggest deal in the world but on this
hand there's already a lot of science
text so it makes a lot of sense it's
gonna give me a lot of value so this is
why what I mean is like 90 of the hand
is comp discount and it's card drop so
there are actually only two cards we
haven't talked about yet and that's veto
and orbital cleanup and these two is
just to get a little bit of money income
because capital and can't discount that
is the major component of this but you
also need a little bit of money income
to actually get the full effect it makes
sense right so if you're going guard
mode Vita is insane in the end of this
video I'm gonna show you like some stats
based on this game I'm about to show you
and beat your seriously just generated
me 222 Mega credit during Seven
Generations an orbital cleanup I think
is also a necessity in this deck because
with all this science tag we are going
to get officer cleanup can give you a
lot of Mega credits and also I have a
Nerf tag and also it's very cheap to
play just because I have so much
discount on Space tags and Vito so let's
actually look at the card discount real
quick so these are the four cards with
Card discount I already chose to have in
my deck and also want to put some
special attention to these five cards I
really hope that I would pick these five
cards up like randomly at the start of
the game I ended up getting Skydive so
that's kind of good person only one out
of five and then way later I got Media
Group and that's a little bit too late
but the reason Media Group and optimal
error braking is so good is because it's
not only discount they actually give you
stuff and you might be thinking well
that's practically the same isn't it but
it's not quite because you're having a
lot of discount on Space tags and then
you play some of these cheap space Tech
instead of it just being you can play it
for zero then you actually get three
Mega credit when you play Space Tag so
what I'm trying to say is when you're
going full god mode actually playing
cards which ends up giving you stuff
that's really good this is also the
whole reason I think meat Industries is
so good when you're going guard mode
this can like generate you so much gold
and then finally before we look at the
game I just wanted to mention these
cards that just straight up give you
stuff it's like the same idea it's
really strong to just get stuff
especially when you go in god mode so
the game I'm about to show you I kind of
played this deck like twice but the
first time I only played the first like
three generations because in in
generation three I was going god mode
and that's when I decided all right this
this is crazy man I have to like just
restart this and just take some pictures
and like document this stuff for you
guys because this is completely insane
so this is why I restarted and then I
went for it again but in the first game
I actually went kind of got modern
generation three the reason the first
game was better is that I picked up
endangered workers and mineral deposit
in the first or the second generation
and that just it makes me like get the
snowball going like one generation
before so I just wanted to mention these
cars these cars are really good so here
we go let me show you how this thing can
go absolutely god mode in four
generations and keep in mind this is not
like a normal game where you start with
effectively 20 Mega credit production
because you have 20 tier new this is
like a solo game so I only had 14 TR and
then I have minus two Mega credit
production to start the game with but
even that doesn't really matter much
because I'm still gonna go God mode on
Generation 4 so this really hammers home
the point I'm trying to make before that
is not all about Mega credit like worth
noting there's no mega credit production
in this starting hand I have like two
from spin-off Department one from new
partner and that's pretty much it then
later on I'm even gonna lose two Mega
credit production Again by playing
orbital cleanup so how on Earth is it
mathematically possible to go broad
motor Generation 4 when I only have this
little resources to begin with so this
is like the end of generation one and as
you can see I didn't really do much I
just played spin-off department and then
also played heavy Taxation and if you're
wondering the two cards I ended up
keeping from corporate archives out of
the seven cars I kept heavy Taxation and
energy market and every taxation that
starts to feel good car at this point it
gives me two Mega credit production and
one Mega credit for free kind of and
then it's a Nerf tag so it doesn't
really cost me a card because I'm just
going to draw another card so it's just
a feel good card at this point an energy
Market does absolutely nothing for me
right now but in Generation 3 I believe
I get Mass converter Quantum extractor
so at that point it's gonna give me like
eight million 27th generation still kind
of good of course these two cards could
have been something better or something
even more impactful but you know you get
seven cars that just pick the two best
here and now get ready for the lamest
thing you've seen all day so this is the
end of generation one so now I'm gonna
show you the end of generation two ready
voila absolutely nothing happens I
simply just passed the generator I
didn't nothing so I want to get 17 Mega
credits I can't really do much to be
honest and of course the other reason I
pass is that I want to play with
catapult now I know it's kind of food by
itself doesn't really do anything so if
I'm not planning to play something
afterwards catapult it's actually better
to weigh the generation because
theoretically I could have just topped
it Earth office or conscription or
something like this so if that had
happened and I already played Earth
catapult and generation two I would have
been really salty so this is why it's
technically correct to only play Earth
catapult the moment you plan on using
the discount effect the moment you plan
on playing something else after Earth
catapult and I will see the change from
the end of generation 2 to the end of
Generation 3 and now stuff is beginning
to happen so now we're getting somewhere
I can play Earth catapult Quantum
extract and mass converter and that also
meant that I could finally play this
energy market so I can transform one
energy production into eight gold which
is really good for me right now and then
of course this is also the time to play
Master University and Olympus conference
I believe I played these before I played
Quantum extractor Mass converter this is
also a good time to play orbital cleaner
because I have a lot of science text now
and also this card with all the discount
I just played is actually kind of cheap
and seriously look at the discount here
in Mars University for instance Mars
University cost exactly one because of
Earth catapult Valley Trust and veto and
the Olympus conference only cost me
three Mega credits and otherwise on
Earth tanks are also draws me account so
you can already see the Synergy really
starting to take form here and then also
picked up some random pretty good cards
here and like I'm saying when you're
drawing this many cards you are bound to
find something some random cards look
really good for you so in this case Luna
Governor kind of cool because it has two
Earth takes that draws me two cards with
Point Luna and then I got interplanetary
Colony shift also a very good card at
this point because I already have a lot
of space Tech discount and now I finally
got my energy I've been running so this
means that I'm actually able to trade in
the Next Generation so now stuff is
finally happening on the map so like you
can see I put it on Sirius and that's
because I really want to trade on
Sarah's Next Generation and that's gonna
give me a lot so these are the three
random colonies I got due to Zero's kind
of cool Titans gonna be completely
useless so now let's look at the
transition from end of Generation 3 to
end of generation 4 and worth noting in
generation 4 this is a first generation
where I'm actually trading so I'm also
getting an extra trade free so this
means that I'm trading on serious and on
Pluto so look at this jump here
seriously end of Generation 3 and now
look at end of generation 4. wow this is
what I mean when I say that I feel like
Generation 4 this is where I've truly
gone god mode I mean this is just
beautiful so I really hope this Nails
home the point that I'm trying to make
today that this card draw Plus Card
discount combo that is so insanely good
because once again remember I started
this game only having 14 TR and -2 make
credit production so started the game
effectively only having access to 12
Mega credits every generation and that's
nothing so going from that to this in
only four generations that is completely
insane so some of the cool stuff I got
in this generation I picked up warp
drive and skydocs this is like maybe the
best cards I picked up right now also
Advanced Airlines was a big one and then
I got Luna metropolis and you might be
thinking oh man you're so lucky you got
these cards but the thing is at this
point normally Drew like 100 cards so I
think this game was like like average
it's not like I was insanely lucky this
is just quite simply how this deck is
going to play out every single time you
can try it yourself if you want to yeah
I'm sure you're going to get it just as
good as a game as this one so just to
give you a little bit of fun stats right
now when we're halfway through the game
at this point Mars University already
allowed me to cycle 15 cards Point Luna
allowed me to draw 22 cards and spin-off
department has drawn me eight cards and
then thanks to the two cards I just
picked up like warp drive and skydives
now I have 13 discount on Space Tech so
let's see what happened from end of
Generation 3 to end of generation 4 on
the map so this is the first generation
where I actually trade it so as you can
see a trademon series on Pluto serious
was flat really good because I ended up
giving I think Spaceport Colony so I
have actually two colonies in service
right now so if you couple that with the
fact that I also picked up Advanced
allies that's like effectively 30 buying
power I'm getting here if I can use all
of this steel so this is why I really
wanted to get a double colony in series
instead of Pluto it might look a little
bit weird but this is definitely worth
it the rest of the game I'm just gonna
speedrun a little bit because the first
few Generations those are actually the
most like interesting to me a little bit
so let's look at the difference between
end of generation 4 to the end of
generation five and as you can imagine
as soon as you've hit this point in the
game where you've gone complete god mode
which I I would argue is generation four
then with generation five six and seven
and then we're gonna close the game in
seven like just just by having three or
four generations of complete god mode
you can do so much with this so I think
you get the idea at this point the only
thing I want to point out with this
generation is that I got a little bit of
Green Tech Synergy decomposes while
enhances venusian animals is kind of
cool and you might be thinking videos in
animal that should be impossible at this
point but here is how the map looked at
the end of generation four and now look
at the end of generation five so when I
picked up venusian animals I really
tried to dedicate this whole generation
to just pumping the Venus up to 18 as
much as I could because then I could
play the news in animals and play some
of the other science tags in my hand so
let's go for end of generation 5 to end
of generation six and yeah like I said
at this point it's of course completely
insane so if we look at the map end of
generation version 5 compared to end of
generation 6. now we're pretty close to
closing the game I think I could have
actually closed the game in this
generation if I wasn't also focused on
getting so many VP but of course I'm I'm
a greedy person I also want the VP and
now finally the difference between end
of Generation 6 to end of generation
seven and there you go this is like more
cards than I play in a normal game of
terraforming mass and finally let's look
at the map the end of Generation 6
compared to the end of generation 7. as
you can see all the parameters has now
been maxed out the board of the oxygen
the temperature and also the Venus and
worth noting because I'm playing Venus
and this is like a solo game I should
have done this solar phase or whatever
it's called where I connect World
Government phase where I'm getting one
zero form rating for free every
generation but I'm not getting it the
world government is actually getting it
but this whole phase I didn't actually
do it because I kind of forgot about it
now it's even harder for me to close the
game but as you can see it's really not
a problem I have so many mega credits
left over that even after closing all
the parameters I still could like fill
up the map a decent amount with like
cities and greeneries and stuff I'd also
want to find out I didn't actually get a
lot of asteroids I didn't get a lot of
heat production I didn't get a lot of
stuff so I could actually close the
temperature so I actually had to make a
lot of standard project with asteroids
so like I think I made seven or eight so
that's like more than 100 gold just to
close the game with these stand-up
projects and it still wasn't a problem
because I was all right at the end of
generation five so at the start of
generation six I had 55 Mega credit
production and also have 45 TR so that's
exactly 100 Mega credits I actually got
at the start of generation six and then
at the end of Generation 6 I actually
had like 144 Mega craters I believe I
got the style of Generation 7 and here
at the end of Generation 7 I'm at 85 TR
and 120 Mega credit so if I played
another generation I would have had more
than 200 megabits in case you're
wondering I kind of wrote down the score
here I don't think it's important but
just with knowing the news in animals
decomposers those two popped off but
that makes sense right because I was
able to play them so early and then I
got three German amplifiers and
naturally with all this discount on
Google Intex is not a problem to play
all of this jobian stuff so that's like
a lot of points and joins as well and
then you might be thinking I'm lucky
that I got three out of four German
amplifiers but I actually also like Drew
three quarters of the neck so it makes
sense together so it's 228 Victory parts
and seven generations and and once again
this doesn't matter at all because this
is I completely cheated I chose my own
starting date but I'm just it's just to
show you how strong this type of synergy
can actually be but here are the fun
steps this is way more fun to talk about
than actually the VP because this is
like the fun stuff so here to the left
you can see the production I ended this
game with the 30 titanium production
that's a little bit misleading because I
actually didn't have that much titanium
version it's just because in the last
iteration I played this lunar Mining and
I only played it like just because it's
it's a cheap Earth tag so I wanted
another card that's pretty much it but
now we get to the good stuff 156 cards
played in this game and then I looked at
around two thirds of the deck it's a
little bit less it was definitely more
than half but the reason I look at so
many cards that's because of Pluto
that's because of Master University and
it's also especially because of high
ticket I ended up having 17 discs
discounts on Space tags and the vital
Corporation actually ended up giving me
222 Mega credits in this game because I
played 74 cards with actually have a
positive Victory on top of it and now
look at this I drew 37 cards off of
Point Luna I drew 30 cards off of
spin-off Department I was able to rotate
28 cars due to Mars University and then
Olympus conference got me 13 cards and
then AI Central is actually a lot worse
than the others because it only drew me
like eight cards but just to find AI
Central a little bit here this is
obviously because this is a like a
completely god mode game so it's not
really a fair comparison normally Air
Center is actually also like almost as
good as the other cars I would say but
yeah that's pretty much it for this
video I hope this was still fun for you
even though this is like a big Theory
craft and it's not necessarily something
you would see in a real game but I still
think the same ideas apply to normal
games like if you want to see a normal
game where I also have a lot of card
draw and a lot of Card discount just
watch the game I talked about before
called the power card draw I just really
felt like I needed to make this video
because I didn't really have around the
fact that I think card brokers discount
card is so good I hope at the very least
you've gotten that impression from this
video that this type of synergy is
really impactful and also Theory graph
is fun man so in the last video I showed
you the other Deck with like some user
made content and I said well if you want
to you can see if you can come up with a
better click than that I'll give you the
same challenge for this video if you
could come up with a fun deck that's
almost as strong as this one or maybe
it's just fun in a different way it's
very creative or something then feel
free to write it in the comments and
I'll talk about it in the episode called
feedback thanks for watching